jamal khashoggi prominent saudi
journalist and washington post columnist
has gone missing after visiting his
country's consulate in istanbul
we knew that they would try to sweep the
whole thing
under the rug the global response the
u.s
response u.n response is bad boy
we're gonna let you get away with this
one
[Applause]
[Music]
in october of 2018 the world learned of
the brutal murder and dismemberment of
washington post columnist jamal
khashoggi
khashoggi had been a government insider
in his home country of saudi arabia
but his relationship with the ruling
family and particularly crown prince
mohammed bin salman or mbs
soured as khashoggi became an
influential advocate for free speech and
human rights within the kingdom
in september 2017 fearing retaliation
he fled to the united states my guest
today is jamal
khashoggi he decided several weeks ago
to leave his country because he felt
that he had become
persona non grata in 2018
khashoggi walked into the saudi
consulate in istanbul turkey to obtain
marriage papers
and was ambushed by a team of government
operatives allegedly deployed by prince
muhammad
as khashoggi's fiance hatisha shanghis
waited outside for him to return
the saudi team went to work his ability
to speak freely
to fight for freedom of speech freedom
of press
um some sort of parliamentary
democracy in this country was so
important to him that he was willing to
to leave and lose everything in order to
do that
and in so doing um
he finds himself in the crosshairs of
muhammad bin salman
and this ultimately leads to his murder
and not just any murder but a brutal
gruesome murder
inside his own country's consulate while
his fiancee
is waiting outside believing that he's
coming out with marriage papers
brian fogle is the oscar-winning
filmmaker behind the 2017 netflix
documentary icarus
99 of russian athletes are guilty of
doping be very careful what was your
recording
his new film the dissident out now on
vod contains shocking audio tapes
transcripts and video surveillance
footage of the saudi operation that
ended with jamal khashoggi being
strangled to death and his body disposed
of in several trash bags that will send
messages to everyone else
you can kill everyone the documentary
features damning revelations such as the
saudi team's efforts to cover up the
murder after the fact by dressing a
khashoggi body double in the slain man's
clothes and parading him in front of
security cameras
you have video of him taking off those
clothes and his fake mustache
so a lot of this seems like they should
have known
or they knew that they could not
possibly get away with this
so how intentional do you think this was
in terms of being a message to the
international community
and what does that say about the saudis
that if they were trying to make this
intentional that they could dismember
somebody in a foreign consulate
and use that as a message to the world i
don't believe that
uh saudi arabia believed they were going
to get caught
i think the murder was botched they
didn't know that there was a listening
device in the consulate they had
actually come
to sweep the consulate for bugs two days
before they murdered khashoggi and
didn't find the bug
that was in the media room clearly they
were trying to plant the murder on
turkey with the body double
they were not expecting the fiancee
uh to be waiting for him outside with
his
phones with his devices
then you know because they would have
confiscated those devices and those
devices you know also revealed pegasus
on his phone
using pegasus a spyware tool that the
saudis allegedly installed to eavesdrop
on khashoggi's conversations
they discovered that he was
communicating with a young dissident
living in canada named omar abdulaziz
i know my jamal was killed it's because
of me
once you start working with us you're
not just a journalist
you're a dissident as the film recounts
prince muhammad also attempted to go
after abdul aziz
there's a team that's going to kill you
soon we see in the film
that before killing and murdering
khashoggi
saudi arabia sends a rendition team
to omar abdulaziz in canada and
he's smart enough to have recorded these
conversations
in which they basically are going omar
come back to saudi arabia we'll make you
famous you'll be
a big celebrity mbs likes you he likes
that you're dissenting against him
he thinks you're great really
the dissident also exposes widespread
efforts to cover up or gloss over
khashoggi's killing
you in the film see agnes calamar go in
front of the u.n human rights committee
lays out this crime that the cia and all
the other intelligence agencies in the
world have validated
and the united nations does nothing
gutierrez doesn't take it to the
security council
it doesn't go to the general assembly
there's no trial
in the hague in the netherlands i mean
right this is just
okay they're too big they're too
powerful they have too much money
and we've got too many allies in the
region and they're too
central in that part of the world in the
region we're just gonna
we're just gonna let this one go the
king firmly denies any knowledge of it
could have been rogue
killers remember an early trump thing is
you know
he had ties to terrorism uh that he was
working with isis and muslim brotherhood
and
uh was friends with bin laden and
basically going oh okay so it's okay to
have that happen
now of course none of that's true he
wasn't working with muslim brotherhood
he wasn't working with isis yes he knew
bin laden he knew bamadin in the 1980s
when the united states was supporting
bin laden
when we thought he was our ally he
wasn't a radical he wasn't a terrorist
sympathizer
basically what the prince need to do is
just unplug
and plug government support
to radicalism and radicalism will die
the radicals in saudi arabia most of
them are within the government
service the government payroll all of a
sudden there was a justification for
why somebody should be murdered in such
a manner and
that should not alter the narrative and
that's you know one of the main reasons
you know why i also want to make the
film though he was fresh off an oscar
win for icarus
fogle says it proved difficult to find
partners willing to make the dissident
and it was only made possible through
the backing of the human rights
foundation
though the documentary premiered at the
2020 sundance film festival to rave
reviews
it was rejected by all major
distributors before being picked up by
briarcliff entertainment
the dissident was ultimately turned down
by a few studios because they feared
reprisal can you just talk about the
challenges that you faced in
distributing the film
so we couldn't have asked for anything
better from the audience response and
the critical reception
but we basically walked out of sundance
without a single offer to acquire the
film it was
a universal pass from all of the major
streamers
all of the major studios and
what was going on behind the scenes
there is that every single one of these
major streamers
major media companies that are now
global
companies made the decision those issues
are not as important
as subscriber growth as being able to
take investment from the kingdom as
protecting your investment and business
interests in the region
um and not upsetting their allies such
as the emirates
and and egypt and india and everywhere
else where
you know saudi arabia is highly invested
um and ultimately when you look at the
saudi investment i mean soft bank is the
world's largest hedge fund
the saudi sovereign wealth fund is the
world's largest fund
for investment and so their tentacles
are so deep
and i understand it i'm not mad at them
i
i understand the predicament i just wish
that we as a society were
valuing human rights and valuing stories
like this
we see now with especially china's box
office being massively opened
um hollywood's you know a lot of
productions are dependent on chinese
rules and they don't want to offend
officials
so do you think that there's a line
beyond which
you know that you can identify that you
know is is immoral for
companies or individuals to engage with
these authoritarian regimes or is it
sort of muddy always these are the
calculated decisions
that businesses and leaders make when
figuring out whether or not you're going
to actually try to
seek justice accountability or punish a
murder and what we see here in this case
the stakes are too high
450 billion dollars worth of things
ordered from
a very rich country saudi arabia if i
say we're going to cut it off
they will get the equipment military
equipment and other things from russia
and china
the alternative is to what lose
hundreds of billions of dollars of
weapon sales
globally uh to not have
that those hundreds of billions of
dollars of liquidity
for investment into outside companies
tech companies banks etc
this change has to be able to take place
and come
just like the arab spring did from
individuals
just like the blm movement just like me
too just like all of these social
justice campaigns
they have to come from the people
because they're not going to come from
the businesses
and it's not going to come from the
government we know that many uh
are trying to uh use this
painful uh thing all our uh mega
projects are ongoing
our war on extremism is ongoing our war
on terrorism is ongoing
uh developing and upgrading the country
is ongoing no matter
what they do to lower our speed or
hinder our speed they will not succeed
the crown prince of saudi arabia a
friend of mine a man who
has really done things in the last
five years in terms of opening up saudi
arabia
we saw the trump administration sweep
this under the rug in a pretty
disgusting way but you know
obama sold arms to saudi it's been the
same way for the you know past several
presidents bush like we've had very
close ties to saudi arabia for all the
reasons that you just mentioned
given how horrific this crime was and
how much publicity it got
is there anything that could happen you
know in geopolitics that could change
that status quo
and do you have any reason to believe
that the blind administration will be
any different
donald trump you know was recorded for
bob woodard's book
uh bragging i saved mbs's ass i mean
this was
intentional but what i did see in going
with atesia to washington
and having her meet with everybody from
nancy pelosi to lindsey graham
i saw a real desire
among both houses bipartisan
that we must re-examine our relationship
with the saudis and there needs to be
some sort of justice for jamal there
needs to be accountability for jamal
and biden has come out publicly second
year anniversary of khashoggi's murder
biden made a public statement uh that if
he was elected president
that he would you know look to
re-examine
the u.s saudi relationship uh seek
accountability for jamal's murder
so he has publicly stated that and i
guess we'll
we'll see how it goes as he takes office
this so-called
davos of the desert the forum that was
designed to attract
international investment the new europe
is the middle east
the uh public investment fund reaching 2
trillion or more
by 2030. outside the political realm is
there any long-term blow back
from this that you're seeing in like the
business community or anything because
mbs had this big vision 2030 there was
the davos in the desert
where you know he was inviting all this
foreign investment a lot of that dried
up
we start to see companies back off about
jamal khashoggi
un says an mp4 video file sent from a
whatsapp account
used by the crown prince infected
bezos's phone
he sent a virus to jeff bezos's phone
which is how
all those techs were released um so you
know
on on net now has that actually impacted
the saudis long term and do you think he
regrets
this or at least regrets that it got out
the funny thing is before the khashoggi
murder
they had done such a good job with that
pr campaign
with mbs's trip to the united states in
march of that year
where he met with you know literally
everybody from
obama to bush to
um bezos to elon musk to larry ellison
to bill gates i mean it was you know
uh and and he was in a suit
and he's young and he was painted
as the great reformer and they bought it
we bought it everybody everybody was
like wow
this guy is really got an open mind he's
going to change
things and what we saw on the khashoggi
murder
his arrest lujan al-hatould woman's
activists the arrests and crackdown of
thousands and thousands of people
dissent who had any opinion of dissent
um the purge at the ritz carlton among
you know other members of his family and
anybody who held wealth in that country
we saw basically the contradictory
actions
of a totalitarian regime
that what was being painted to the
outside world
and being supported through uh you know
a massively funded
pr campaign was the exact
opposite of what was really going on in
the kingdom and that's what put jamal
in mbs's way because jamal was out there
going okay
this is great that you want to do all
these things and all of this is positive
for our country
but you can't do that and also lock up
people and behead them and
uh and put them on trial
and torture their families and etc etc
if they don't agree with you that's not
that's not evolving that's you know
that's the dark ages
and jamal spoke up about that and that
is
you know one of the one if not the key
reason
why they murdered him that is what i'm
fearful of
he it is becoming a one-man rule he has
a control of everything he is creating
an environment of uh
of of of intimidation and and fear
surroundings are being silenced things
are not being transparent
and that is not a good recipe for reform
in saudi arabia
fogel says he's most passionate about
seeking justice and accountability for
whistleblowers dissidents and other
victims of totalitarian governments
around the world
were you the mastermind that cheated the
olympics
yes the film for which he won an oscar
in 2017
icarus provided crucial evidence on the
russian olympics doping scandal
based on revelations from the former
head of moscow's internationally
certified drug testing laboratory
grigori rochenkov
who worked with kremlin officials to
implement the scheme
[Applause]
was putin aware of the existence of the
russian doping system
yes this all can be proved it's quite
mind-blowing
in the case of icarus you know me and my
team ended up
literally protecting the life of a
whistleblower
bringing him to the united states uh
bringing his story to the new york times
then following that story
shepherding him into protection to this
day have
continued to try to protect him will
kill me
holy [ __ ] two people connected with the
russian doping program are already dead
the fallout of icarus was five months
after the film came out russia was
banned
from the 2018 olympics and the ioc the
olympic committee cited icarus in their
region
recent decision so all these factors you
know just
made me feel as you know a documentary
in a storyteller
that wanted to continue on you know
journeys like that making stories like
that
knowing that the content really uh
had a global importance of human rights
the story of a of not only a horrific
murder but
in omar abdul aziz his family is and
friends and brothers are jailed without
charges
uh beheadings 900 beheadings last year
most from young activists um
and you know the list goes on and on and
you mentioned omar abdulaziz
uh that's one of the other particularly
wrenching moments that i found from the
film was when
he got a call from his brother begging
him to stop
because the saudi government was
torturing his
his brothers um or that he's he said he
had 22 of his friends and his brothers
have remained in solitary confinement in
jeddah
icarus also featured you know astounding
tales of
this whistleblower who gave up
everything to tell his story
so what insight has that given you into
what kind of a person does that
and how is how is that worth it for him
to have
everybody that's ever known in his life
be tortured and imprisoned in order to
reveal this i felt deeply connected to
heteja and the lost that this woman was
going for
and i wanted to and still want to help
her
and roll up my sleeves and help her
fight for justice for jamal because it
shouldn't just be her
and i became deeply connected and
found you know
a brother and omar abdulaziz and his
journey and i saw his truth was so
important
that he was willing to do and is willing
to do anything for that
and the fact that his brothers would
be tortured and sit in a prison for two
years without charges
simply because they know him and simply
because
he is speaking truth to power um
that's why i made the movie i made the
movie to try to
make an impact in the world and to fight
for justice for jamal
so that his voice was in silence